you mentioned the Brotherhood without
banners and and you're in your
relationship with them is an amazing one
they're incredibly loyal these groups
that do meet you you know and and
outside of the book signings and have
such a relationship with you have they
ever impacted the stories have they
impacted the characters and the plots
and and what's actually happening in a
Song of Ice and Fire
no that's any appreciable extent you
know much as I love my fans I've also
been known to say artists is not a
democracy I don't encourage people to
make suggestions to me or story ideas I
mean for one thing it opens you up to
potential lawsuits know 99% of the the
fans out there are great and would never
do that but there's always the one you
know lunatic who who says you know why
don't you have a sword fight in the next
book and then if there's a sword he
stole my idea you know and and they find
some Yahoo lawyer in in you know
boondock North Dakota who will file so
you you have to beware that you have to
establish that you don't take other
people's ideas and you can't always do
the popular thing I mean that's what
that's the mistake two networks make in
the studios with these focus groups and
test things where you know they test an
ending to see if it will be populated a
tested character
you know you need characters that people
aren't gonna like you need people that
aren't you know appreciated they they
drive the the story and sometimes you
have concepts or ideas that are not
immediately popular but nonetheless are
the right thing to do to tell your story
I mean if I had voted if I had said okay
fans should I kill Ned at the end of the
first book he would still be kicking
around I mean nobody he would have voted
to kill him but nonetheless killing him
was was the right thing to do at least
for me in my readers now that being said
I I acknowledge that my books are not
for every
I have gotten many letters over the
years from people who say well I was I
was enjoying your books but then you
know you you killed my favorite
character and now or never read them
again how could you do that I'd I read
your books for I read for pleasure and
relaxation I don't like to be you know
kicked in the groin by authors and and
that's fine and you know I understand
where they're coming from and there are
plenty of books out there by by writers
who will not kick you in the groin
there's people who are doing comfort
fiction where the hero is always going
to win the sword fight and is always
gonna be safe and the heroine is never
gonna be raped and you know everything
is going to come out well at the end it
just doesn't happened to me the books I
write in the books I write I want you
not to know what the hell is going to
happen and to Lovan mortal fear about
what may happen when you turn the next
page and who's gonna live in who's gonna
die that's my goal there are a lot of
people here who like to be kicked in the
groin